well Donald Trump is siding with
Democrats on the issue of the debt
ceiling it's total chaos and we still
have no reason to think that Donald
Trump actually understands the issue and
the details and the complexity of the
debt ceiling every time Trump does
something that seems to break with the
Republican Party Republicans are asked
about it and the ones that wanted to say
a defend Trump will either say oh it's
an act of bipartisanship or this is
proof that he's his own man he's not
just another typical politician he
thinks for himself and takes the
position he believes to be right and of
course that's ridiculous right Trump has
no overriding political philosophy that
would inform decisions like about the
debt ceiling his guiding principles have
always been and continue to be greed and
self enrichment and self aggrandizement
period so before we break down what
happened with Donald Trump and Democrats
we should first explain what the debt
ceiling is and what the limit is and why
it matters right now okay the debt
ceiling is the upper limit of the amount
of money that the government can borrow
as decided on set by our elected
officials Republicans regularly like to
say Oh can't increase the debt ceiling
too expensive we're fiscally
conservative let's pay down the debt
rather than increase it and of course if
they want to lower the debt why do they
want to cut taxes for the rich which
according to everything from common
sense to detailed reports on the matter
indicate that Trump's tax plan would
increase the debt as a result of cutting
taxes on the rich makes no sense
political posturing but let's put that
aside for a second the real problem with
the debt ceiling is actually there are
many problems with the debt ceiling that
most people aren't aware of but before
we even talk about some of the more
specifics we need to understand why the
entire discussion in the media about the
debt ceiling is total BS because you're
not being told very fundamental facts
that would influence your understanding
and opinion of the debt ceiling I'm
gonna tell you three important things
about the debt ceiling
number one the debt ceiling does not
actually limit limit government deficits
why because spending is
arised by separate legislation you can
pass any debt ceiling limit that you
want and it will have no impact on
Congress passing any spending that they
want in separate bills or legislation it
will prevent the Treasury from paying
for those expenditures and that's where
you start hearing about government
shutdown but we are talking about two
totally different things
number two the debt ceiling is
completely separate from the federal
budget no matter what the debt ceiling
is a budget can be passed that increases
the deficit and thus the debt decreases
it whatever the debt ceiling has no
impact on the budget deficit that might
be passed or added or whatever the case
may be and number three and this is
maybe the most important thing people
often don't get when they just say hey
we shouldn't be increasing the debt
ceiling constantly the debt ceiling is
an aggregate figure okay that means it's
a number of dollars this is probably the
most relevant and most often missing
fact lots of politicians complain we
can't just constantly raise the debt
ceiling well we have a country whose
economy grows and there's inflation
here's how to think about this think
about a small business right imagine you
have a small business the revenues are a
hundred thousand dollars per year you
say okay let's set our debt limit the
most we're willing to borrow how far
into debt were willing to go to remain
in good financial shape we'll call it
five thousand dollars okay that's our
debt ceiling it works out to five
percent you've got a hundred thousand
dollar business think of it as the
economy and you set the debt ceiling at
five thousand dollars next year business
grows to two hundred thousand dollars
and in order to support that growth and
accelerated we say oh we want to buy
more machines we want to hire more
people we want to use debt in order to
do that but damn our debt ceiling is
five thousand dollars but because the
business has grown that same five
thousand dollar debt limit now only
represents two and a half percent of the
business so really if you're comfortable
carrying five percent of your business
in debt you should raise the debt
ceiling to ten thousand dollars from
five thousand dollars
oh we doubled our debt ceiling but it's
still just 5% of your business this is
what people miss the American economy
grows and we also have inflation if you
set a debt ceiling in dollars rather
than in percent as your country grows
and as prices rise due to inflation you
have to raise the debt ceiling
constantly without it necessarily
representing an increase in the portion
of your economy that the debt represents
now this is a separate argument from
what should the debt ceiling be but any
complaint from a politician that they
are against regularly raising the debt
ceiling well in context compared to what
I hope everybody understands what I'm
saying here right debt ceiling is a
billion and then Congress passes and
says well it'll be 2 billion well how
does that relate to the size of the
economy all right it's that sort of
clear pat like is that does that make
sense in general it's a whole thing it's
a whole rundown but as you'd imagine the
size of the economy grows you have to
raise it by more and more in terms of
pure dollars raw dollar that's the idea
that's the general idea so let's cut to
Trump right Trump cuts a deal with
Democratic leaders Nancy Pelosi in the
house Chuck Schumer in the Senate to
raise the debt limit short term in
connection with also needing hurricane
relief funds this would be a three month
raised to the debt ceiling this I
actually believe is an unforced error
for Trump politically I agree with the
decision but I believe it's an unforced
error because he's straining the
relationships with Republican leaders
Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan who he did
not have great relationships with before
by the way and in addition to that
you're only pushing this down the road
by three months you'll be in the exact
same situation in three months it
postpones a bigger decision on the debt
ceiling it's the right thing we needed
to do this in order to continue adding
funds for hurricane relief which we need
but from a merely political standpoint
it's just chaos and nonsense from Trump
I just think that everything's backwards
in this latest chapter of the debt
ceiling debacle because in this case you
actually have Democrats that are trying
to make it only three-month extension
whereas Republicans were pushing for an
18 month and then Wright negotiated down
to a six month extension at first and
then also Democrats would have been in a
position where they had to oppose a
legislative package that would have
brought hurricane
RV relief aid imagine the campaign ads
that that could have been created if
Trump opposed raising the debt ceiling
and then put together a package where
Democrats have to get in opposition to
it and it also includes hurricane relief
it could have been politically
disastrous for Democrats and Trump kind
of gave them a safe and then after the
meeting concluded Donald Trump came away
from it saying that maybe he would be in
support of a dreamers act that would
make official the Obama daca executive
order that yes just rescinded a few days
ago all over the place I mean
unintelligible and bizarre but at least
we will get the hurricane relief funding
that we need the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership